- We have an incredible show today, y'all.
Joining us is one of the funniest,
most groundbreaking comedians
in the history of American
television and film.
She's won a Tony, a Grammy, six Emmys,
and seven Golden Globes,
'cause why the hell not?
(crowd giggles)
Winning all of them.
She was awarded the
Presidential Medal of Freedom,
as well as the Mark Twain
Prize for American Humor.
Tonight on NBC, you can
actually watch her tribute,
it's called, "Carol Burnett,
90 Years of Laughter and Love."
It's incredible.
(audience applauding)
And today happens to be her 90th birthday.
Everybody, give it up for
the iconic Carol Burnett.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(crowd applauds)
Hello.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Keep it coming.
(crowd cheering)
Oh my gosh.
- Thank you.
- We're so excited you are here.
- [Carol] Oh, I'm so excited to be here.
- I feel like my show just
made it, that you're on it.
- Oh God.
(crowd cheering)
- We're very excited, today
is a very special day.
Obviously, happy birthday.
- Thank you.
- It was my birthday two days ago.
- Your birthday is the 24th?
- 24th, yeah.
- And I'm the 26th.
- [Kelly] 26th, yeah.
- You're with also Shirley
McClain and Barbara Streisand.
- Don't you think I know it, girl?
Yes, I was very excited as a kid, yeah.
There's a lot of tourists is killing it,
just saying, we're pretty cool.
We're both from Texas as well.
- [Carol] That's right, yeah.
- Yes, was it San Antonio?
- San Antonio.
- Yeah, do you miss anything?
Because you were young when
you moved to Hollywood, right?
- It was back in the covered wagon days.
(audience laughing)
- The orange,
(Kelly giggles)
- I went to David Crockett Grammar School.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- In San Antonio, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's what, I like San Antonio.
- It was alive then.
- No, it was not.
(crowd giggles)
I miss the queso.
I miss chips and queso from Texas.
That's my favorite thing.
- The best Mexican food ever.
- The Tex-Mex, yes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] I know.
- That's the first food I remember eating.
- [Kelly] Yeah, 'cause it was.
- Enchiladas.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, and then I had my milk, you know.
(crowd giggles)
- Then I had my bottle.
- Yeah, bottle of milk.